in order for the audience to believe in
and be engaged by a Shakespearean
character they have to come across as a
real person on the stage or maybe we
have no error so you go when I read that
when they said they have to come across
as a real person on the stage the way
that the sentence was constructed it
looks like they're referring to the
audience in order for the audience to do
this thing they the audience has to come
across as a real person on the stage
well that's not what they're talking
about they're really talking about the
actors so this day here is confusing it
could be are they talking with the
audience are they talking about the the
characters on stage so I would say the
error right here is in Part C and I
would change they to the if I were
editing this I would change this to the
actors the actors have to come across as
a well actually I would say the actors
it will you dealer say the actors have
to come across have to come across as
real people or you could say the actor
the actor has to come across as a real
person on the stage so that would feel a
lot better in order for the audience to
believe in and be engaged by a
Shakespearean character and that's good
we're doing a Shakespearean character
not Shakespearean characters so that's
why it's good to do lay the singular
right over here the actor has to come
across as a real person on the stage so
this feels much better and so I would
definitely say the error was in Part C